Ach so, ja, da habe ich mir gerade auch schon wieder anhören müssen, dass dieser Vergleich ja auch ein bisschen politisch unkorrekt ist. Aber diese gekaperten Computer, also viele von den Hörern zu Hause, werden eigentlich da nicht schuldig sein in der Teilnahme von diesen DDOS-Attacken, sondern vielleicht eher eurer Eltern zum Beispiel. Eure Eltern, die vielleicht in ihrem Browser keinen Adblocker haben oder so, wo dann irgendwo ein großes Banner blinkt, irgendwie sie haben ein Virus auf ihrem Rechner und dann klicken die da vielleicht drauf. Und dann werden sie in irgendeine einfache Installationsanleitung geleitet, um sich irgendwas zu installieren, was dann eventuell dafür sorgt, dass der Rechner Fernsteuerer wird.
Das ist das, was im Dezember immer weniger wird. Jeder zog in das Land, wo er geboren wurde und fixte die Computer der Eltern.
Aber ich kann verstehen, warum du jetzt Angst hast, dass das politisch Unkrieg genannt wird. Weil, also über die Wortwahl der Gespräche auch noch heute, du hast ja gesagt, schuldig sind, am Botnetz teilzuhaben. Und das ist ja schon victim blaming. Also deine Maschine ist gekapert worden, du bist also schuld. Und Eltern ist halt auch so, ich habe euch auch so einen Tweet gesehen, wo jemand gesagt hat, ja irgendwie meine, also weil jetzt irgendwie die Mutter, die es nicht kann oder so was, hat jemand gesagt, ja meine Mutter hat gerade irgendwie sich voller Begeisterung, keine Ahnung, was auch immer, so ein Video-Ding installiert und Video telefoniert jetzt mit ihren Enkeln. Aber sozusagen, es gibt halt einfach, es gibt halt Menschen, die sich für Technik interessieren, also die sie nicht nur benutzen, sondern auch das dahinterliegen. Es gibt halt Menschen, die sagen, ja das ist schön, dass das Ding bunt ist und Internet macht, aber mehr will ich darüber auch nicht wissen. Und das Problem ist, dass es angreifbar ist.
Ich finde das doch eigentlich völlig legitim, dass Leute diesen Kram einfach nur benutzen können wollen. Ich meine, wenn ich einen Führerschein mache und Auto fahre, dann möchte ich auch nicht irgendwie den Motor neu einstellen können müssen und so.
Aber dann hast du einen Führerschein.
Es gibt ja einen Computerführerschein.
Aber ich glaube tatsächlich nicht, dass der Führerschein der richtige Vergleich ist. Ich meine, wenn du Auto fährst, ist der Vergleich zum Computerding nicht, dass du einen Führerschein hast. Sondern der Vergleich ist, dein Auto hat TÜV. Also jemand anders kümmert sich darum, dass dein Auto in einem Zustand ist, dass du es auf der Straße bewegen kannst, ohne dass es eine Gefahr für andere ist.
Das ist aber leider etwas kaputt. Und zwar hast du mit einem Auto die Menge, die Menschen, die du damit verletzen kannst, theoretisch ist begrenzt, also stark begrenzt. Gehen wir mal von 2000 oder so aus. Mit einem Computer kannst du viel mehr machen.
Jeder Vergleich hinkt. Und natürlich hat ein einzelner Computer auch eine bestimmte Macht. Das Schlimme ist sozusagen, dass man aus vielen Computern, im Gegensatz zu vielen Autos, die sich nicht so am Optimus transformieren, sondern einfach einzelne Autos bleiben.
Und es sind vielleicht auch übers Internet bald fernsteuerbar.
Was für eine großartige Idee. Was kann da nur schiefgehen? Lass uns das Auto ans Internet anstehen.
Das war eine großartige Überleitung, meinst du?
Genau, wir wollen jetzt übers Internet of Things reden, was in den Schlagzeilen war aufgrund dieser Tacke. Und bevor wir das machen, wollten wir eigentlich noch eine Zuschauerfrage beantworten. Fällt mir jetzt gerade auf. Genau. Bitte stellen Sie die Zuschauerfrage. Jetzt ist das Mikrofon wieder weggenommen worden. Was ist denn da nur los? Meine Güte, eine Live-Sendung. Sie können zugucken an der Marienstraße 11. Eine Zuschauerfrage.
Die Frage war in Bezug auf das Problem der DNS-Störungen. Ob es nicht anratbar ist, einfach um sicher zu gehen, Dienste, die einem wichtig sind, sich die IP als Links hinterlegen, im Bookmarks-Liste oder sonst wo. Und andererseits auch für die Serverbetreiber irgendwo rechts unten überall ihre IP-Adresse direkt als Link anzubieten, damit man die bookmarken kann. Dann gäbe es das DNS-Problem ja in dem Moment dann nicht oder in den Fällen nicht.
Also mal abgesehen davon, dass das sozusagen eine technische Lösung ist, die glaube ich daran scheitert, dass das Konzept IP-Adresse auch erst mal vermittelt werden müsste. Also sagen für die Leute, die sich halt genau nicht für die Technik interessieren wollen. Aber ansonsten ist das eine gute Idee?
Es wird in der Praxis nicht funktionieren aus mehreren Gründen. Das eine ist eine IP-Adresse, ohne dass der Hostname vom Webbrowser angefragt wird, geht nicht, weil der dazu gebraucht wird. Das heißt, man müsste die dann noch mal irgendwo anders reinfriegeln, aber auch wenn man das hinbekommt, ist das ja so, dass die Angreifer den Server überlasten. Also in einem Fall, wo ich dann nicht das DNS-System angreife, sondern die Server funktionieren nicht, das ist das eine. Das andere ist, diese IP-Adressen von den Diensten ändern sich so schnell und sind auch für jeden, je nachdem, wo man es aufruft, andere, dass diese Liste innerhalb von wenigen Minuten veraltet ist. Als Beispiel zum Beispiel Google, wenn man zu Hause die IP-Adresse von www.google.de rausbekommt oder auflöst mit so einem kleinen Tool, dann kommen da sechs IP-Adressen raus. Wenn ich dieselbe Anfrage über www.google.de von meinem Handy stelle, kommen da sechs andere IP-Adressen raus. Google ändert ununterbrochen, je nachdem, von wo man anfragt, die Server-Adressen, auf denen die Suchseite ist, weil sie darüber die Lastverteilung machen, über die ganzen Anfragen. Das kann aber sein, dass morgen unter den selben IP-Adressen YouTube zu erreichen ist und nicht mehr die Google-Startseite. Weil die Dienste da ganz schnell durchrotiert werden, weil sie damit die ganzen Lastspitzen abfangen. Oder auch mal einfach solche Server in Wartung nehmen, die dann einfach nicht verfügbar sind, weil die vielleicht mal neu installiert werden.
Gut, das hilft auch nicht. Da kommen wir jetzt aber wirklich, nachdem wir es schon oft genug angekündigt haben, zum Internet of Things. Wir haben übrigens Internet of Things hier. Und wir haben ein Internet of Things.
Das ist eine sogenannte Dockstar.
Was macht das?
Das war mal von Siegert dafür gedacht, dass man seine Festplatte da reinsteckt, seine tragbare USB-Festplatte, das dann hinten mit dem Kabel in sein Internet steckt und dann zu Hause auf die Daten drauf zugreifen kann und auch von unterwegs. Also eigentlich total praktisch.
Klingt ja erstmal gut, aber wie kann ich damit den DNS-Service von Twitter angreifen?
Das Problem an dieser Klasse von Geräten ist, damit ich von außen darauf zugreifen kann, müsste man ja eigentlich zu Hause seinen Router umkonfigurieren, dass man von außen unter der Adresse zu Hause das Ding erreicht. Das ist aber technisch anspruchsvoll. Das müsste man ja Leuten beibringen und vermitteln und schwierig. Dann müsste man wissen, welche Router die da haben. Also hat Siegert sich was anderes ausgedacht. Dieses Ding baut einen VPN-Tunnel zum Hersteller auf. Man kann dann auf einer Webseite vom Hersteller in der Cloud auf die Daten zugreifen. Das heißt, Siegate kann auch auf alle deine Daten zugreifen. Oder einen Angreifer, der den Dienst drauf macht.
Das ist ja ganz großartig, aber das greift immer noch nicht den SRW-Computer an.
Genau, aber das war jetzt als Beispiel von Klasse von Geräten. Das, was angegriffen hat, waren wohl im Wesentlichen IP-Kameras und Babyfone. Also Webcams mit Internetanschluss oder so Überwachungskameras. Weil diese Geräte haben mit dem hier zu gemein, dass da drauf ein vollwertiges Linux, ein vollwertiges Betriebssystem, ein vollwertiger Rechner läuft. Mit allen Diensten, die man da so hat, mit Remote-Login, mit einem Web-Server, damit man sich die Bilder angucken kann und so weiter. Und was jetzt bei diesen Kameras passiert ist, die haben ab Werk einen bestimmten Nutzernamen und Passwort, um darauf zuzugreifen. Und die waren alle im Internet.
Also ich kaufe eine Kamera und die kann nicht in Internet hängen.
Genau.
Und die hat vom Werk vorhin gestelltenen Benutzernamen und Passwort.
Admin zum Beispiel, sehr gerne.
Warte, warte, meine Detailfrage wäre jetzt gewesen, hat die Kamera, die ich gekauft habe, eine Benutzername und Passwort, oder haben alle Kameras dieses Hersteller denselben Benutzernamen, denselben Benutzernamen?
Und das Problem gab es auch schon irgendwie bei einer Kamera, die bei Aldi verkauft wurde letztes Jahr, wo dann die Firmen einen Bug hatten und sie nicht wussten, wie sie den Kunden sagen sollen, dass sie jetzt mal updaten sollen, weil sie wissen ja nicht mal, wer ihre Kunden sind und Auto Update war kaputt.
Nur mal so, aber das haben so gut wie alle Devices. Es gibt ausnahmsweise mal so Fritz-Boxen oder so, die dich dazu zwingen, das zu ändern. Der Rest hat so ein Standardkram.
Tatsächlich habe ich in den letzten Jahren, jeder Router, den ich gesehen hatte, hatte ein eigenes Passwort. Da war dann so eine fiese Zeichenther, die man sich merkt.
Aber wenn du dir das genauer anguckst, gibt es durchaus Hersteller, wo dann dieses Passwort aus einem festen Präfix besteht. So abc, Unterstrich und dann der Rest von der MAC-Adresse, also von der Netzwerkadresse von dem Gerät.
Was ist eine Netzadresse von einem Gerät?
Das ist eine eindeutige ID, mit der dieses Ding im Netzwerk angesprochen werden kann, die MAC-Adresse. Das ist so ein hexadezimaler Zahlencode. Damit ist das im lokalen Netz identifizierbar. Das Problem ist, dass die auch per WLAN verschickt wird in jedem Datenpaket. Und wenn man das dann sieht, dann ist auch klar, wie das Passwort das ist.
Also entweder ist das Gerät, das bei mir zu Hause ans Netz hänge, und das ein vollwertiger Computer ist, zumindest was jetzt die Ausführung von DDOS-Attacken angeht, hat entweder ein gesetztes Standardpasswort, was auf allen Geräten gleich ist, nämlich Admin und Passwort 1, 2, 3, 4, oder es hat aus einem Algorithmus errechnet das Passwort, und der Algorithmus errechnet das aber aus einer Zahlenfolge, die das Gerät mit jedem Datenpaket in den Äther bläst. Zum Beispiel. Genau. Das macht doch gar keinen Sinn. Doch. Warum?
Na doch, für die Hersteller schon, weil es ist total einfach dem Kunden zu sagen, wie sein Passwort ist, wenn er es vergessen hat.
Aber das ist doch dumm.
Ja.
Ja, aber billig.
Da hat einer nicht weitergedacht.
Es ist halt billig. Es ist wenig Supportaufwand.
Entschuldigung, was mich jetzt ein bisschen irritiert, wir haben noch 50 Minuten bis Sendungsende. Und ich dachte sozusagen, ihr erklärt mir jetzt lang und ausführlich, was das grundlegende Problem sozusagen daran ist, warum so viele Internet of Things-Sachen gehackt haben. Jetzt sagt ihr, das liegt einfach nur daran, dass es passt.
Wir machen hier gerade die gleichen Fehler nochmal, wie wir sie mit den normalen Rechnern schon vor 20 Jahren hatten oder vor 15. So, ich sag nur so Windows 98, Windows XP. Also diese gleiche Klasse an Bugs, die sich irgendwie relativ leicht exploiten lassen, die führen wir jetzt alle wieder ein. Weil diese Devices müssen für wenig Geld verkauft werden. Dieser Stein hier, den wir hier liegen haben, der spricht Internet und der kostet drei Euro. Und für drei Euro...
Entschuldigung, was? Das ist der neueste Hype.
Könnte mal einer vom Publikum vielleicht kommen?
Das ist so groß wie eine halbe Briefmarke.
Wer traut sich in die Kamera? Einmal dieses kleine Ding nehmen und das mal ganz dicht in die Kamera halten, nur damit man eine Idee von der Größenordnung kriegt.
Auf dem Ding läuft jetzt kein volles Betriebssystem, aber das kostet drei Euro.
Na gut, lass mich fragen. Kann ich damit eine DDOS-Attacke machen?
Ja, es kann halt nicht sehr viel Daten senden. So ein 300-Kilo-Bit habe ich gestern mal ausprobiert.
Aber ist ja gar nicht.
Wenn die das amplifieren und reflekten und mit ordentlicher Verstärkung, wenn das viele von den Geräten machen, könnte das auch böse werden. Und die Dinger kannst du halt in Python programmieren, zum Beispiel in einer sehr einfachen Programmiersprache. Schließt man Rechner an, kann man programmieren und direkt loslegen. Die haben auch WLAN drin, das ist ein Access-Point.
Bitte, das Ding hat WLAN drin?
Das Ding hat WLAN drin.
Was ist dieses goldene Ding da drauf?
Das ist ein Access-Point. Das Ding, was jetzt Bento gerade hochhebt, ist derselbe Baustein nur mit ein bisschen Platine drumrum. Der hat übrigens hier gerade ein WLAN aufgemacht. IoT ESP 266. Passwort fürs WLAN ist dasselbe wie SSID. Ihr könnt versuchen, das zu hacken. Und das Ding macht selber ein Access-Point auf, vergibt eine IP-Adresse an dein Handy, wenn du dich damit verbindest. Kann auch selber in ein WLAN reingehen, kann dann da E-Mails versenden und kann auch auf eine WLAN scannen und so weiter.
Also das Ding kann vollwertige Dinge im Internet tun. Und das ist die Frage, von wohin war?
Es kann für dich twittern oder sonst was.
Und DDOSen?
Es könnte DDOSen, wenn es viele sind. Also die Performance von den Dingen reicht jetzt beim Item nicht.
Aber ich hab ja nicht nur eins, ich hab 150.000.
Raspberry Pi, sehr beliebt.
Oder noch mal in klein, den Raspberry. So groß wie eine halbe Kreditkarte.
Okay, also für die Leute, die jetzt wirklich... Entschuldigung, ich hab's vergessen. Ich war jetzt so fasziniert von der Technik, ich hab's vergessen. Es tut mir leid. Auch für die Leute, die jetzt nur den Podcast hören. Also dieses kleine Ding, würde ich sagen, aber jetzt zeigt das mal an die Kamera. Das ist halt wirklich sozusagen so groß wie ein Daumen. So einen Raspberry Pi kennt man. Da gibt's hier die eine Variante, die ist im Prinzip wie eine Checkkarte ein bisschen größer, weil noch eine SD-Karte rausguckt und ein bisschen höher, weil eine Netzwerkbuchse dran ist. Dann gibt's aber die nächste Version, die ist so...
Halbe Kreditkarte.
Genau, halbe Kreditkarte und auch ohne Netzwerkbuchse. Die kann aber auch WLAN vermutlich.
Die kann dann WLAN, wenn du einen WLAN-Stick für 3 Euro anschließt. Den hab ich auch dabei.
Ah, okay, verstehe.
Wie gesagt, du merkst, die Sachen sind halt billig. 3 Euro, 5 Euro, 10 Euro.
Ich finde es auch von der Größe her interessant, weil ich glaube, dass... Ich finde es interessant, dass ein vollwertiger Computer diese Größeordnung haben kann. Weil ich glaube, dass... Dass diese ganzen Dinge, die wir uns jetzt nach Hause holen sollen, wenn man der Industrie folgt, das Internet of Things ist das nächste große Ding und das wird alles ganz super. Du stellst dir deine Lampe, hängst sie dir rein, kannst sie dir ein paar Wehle anschauen und so was. Es gibt da eine gefühlte Wahrheit, wenn man sich nicht mit diesem Thema explizit beschäftigt hat, wo man denkt, na ja, das ist ja nur so klein.
Da kann ja nicht viel passieren.
Genau, da kann ja nicht viel passieren. Das ist ja nur ein Feuerzeug und nicht ein Herd. Ich finde es interessant, das wirklich mal explizit zu sehen, dass man sagen kann, okay, dieses Ding, das kann halt tatsächlich in der Glühlampe sozusagen, in dem Sockel einer Glühbirne, könnte man das unterbringen.
Wird es ja auch getan. Diese LED-Glühlampe, die es gibt, die haben dann ja WLAN drin. Die machen einen Access Point auf zum Konfigurieren. Dann hast du deine App auf deinem Handy, konfigurierst das Ding, danach ist das in deinem WLAN drin. Das Ding ist halt, das Zeug kostet nichts. Das sind 3 bis 5 Euro. Wenn du dir jetzt überlegst, dass die dann Geräte entwickeln, wo das drin ist, die Geräte kosten dann vielleicht 20 Euro, 30, 40, vielleicht auch mal 50. Das ist eine einmalige Einnahme von den Herstellern, wenn sie das Ding verkaufen. Aber um die Sachen sicher zu machen, müssen sie ja regelmäßig Firmenupdates bereitstellen. Weil du benutzt das Ding ja ein paar Jahre.
Also einerseits ja. Ich meine, okay, da ist halt Co drauf und Co, da werden vielleicht irgendwann Fehler gefunden. Und die müssen wir verbessern. Dann gibt es das Problem mit den Updates. Aber wir reden ja immer noch über diese Nummer, da wird ein Standardpasswort verwendet. Also eins für alle Geräte. Wie geht denn das überhaupt? Ihr seht mich sozusagen etwas fassungslos an die Webseite.
Es ist halt schwierig. Wenn du auf jedem Gerät ein anderes Passwort haben möchtest, musst du in der Fabrik, bei der Herstellung, für jedes Gerät die Firmware anpassen. Du kannst nicht überall eins zu eins die selbe drauf kopieren. Deswegen fangen sie halt an, ich nehme einen Algorithmus, der das aus der Markadresse oder aus irgendwas anderem ableitet. Dann habe ich den Vorteil, ich kann Aufkleber auf die Packung kleben. Da steht die Seriennummer drauf, da steht das Passwort drauf. Aber diese Algorithmen lassen sich sehr oft zurückrechnen. Das war auch bei diesen ganzen WLANs in den letzten Jahren immer mal wieder so, dass dann zum Beispiel ISPs, Kabelnetzbetreiber oder so, haben die Kunden WLAN-Access Points hingestellt. Da war ein Passwort dann gesetzt, was zufällig aussah, was sich aber aus der Seriennummer, der Markadresse, aus irgendwas ableiten ließ. Und dann gab es entweder nicht so viele Kombinationen dafür, oder man konnte eben aus dem, was im WLAN gesendet wurde, zurückrechnen auf das Passwort. Was halt eigentlich eine gute Idee ist, damit die Support-Leute den Leuten sagen können, dein Passwort ist dieses, wenn sie es nicht geändert haben, oder dass man nach dem Reset vom Gerät noch dran kommt, weil dann wieder das Passwort ist, was draufklebt. Und es einfach nicht zu verwalten ist, jedes Mal ein komplett zufälliges Passwort zu setzen, dann ein Label auszudrucken und auf das Gerät zu kleben. Und im Prinzip müssten die aber eigentlich alle so gestrickt sein, dass beim Einschalten des Gerätes zwangsweise ein Passwort gesetzt werden muss. Das muss man sich dann irgendwo aufschreiben und unten aufs Gerät draufkleben und das ist dann das Passwort. Nur dann müsstest du auch die Leute dazu zwingen, dass sie da immer ein sicheres Passwort für nehmen und nicht den Namen ihres Hundes. Deswegen ist eigentlich ein vom Hersteller vorgegebenes, zufälliges Passwort als Einstieg, als Default, wenn der Kunde nichts macht, eine gute Idee. Nur müssen die Algorithmen eben sicher sein.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn es wirklich zufällig wäre, ich würde sogar dazu was sagen. Das sind jetzt alle Spielzeuge, die wir haben. Also Dinge, die, also bis auf die Seagate. Aber ja, noch so? Besser? Der Punkt ist, wir haben noch andere Sachen, wo der normale Benutzer das gar nicht vermutet, dass da sowas drin ist. Und zwar zum Beispiel ein Thermomix mit WLAN. Da denkt keiner drüber nach, was das ist. Genau, Fernseher, Kühlschränke mit Internet. Es gibt so viele Sachen, wo Internet drin ist, wo wir aber nicht drüber nachdenken, dass die auch ganz andere Sachen können.
Also, na okay, soweit war ich jetzt. Ausnahmsweise doch schon. Jedes Gerät, was ans Netzwerk angeschlossen ist, ist tendenziell sozusagen Netzwerk. Also, jetzt kriege ich jetzt total lobe, wenn man das so sagt. Aber im Prinzip ist das auch die Quintessenz.
Das ist halt das Internet of Things. Der Internetteil ist zwar durchaus ernst zu nehmen, ja.
Da steht aber nicht auf den Geräten meistens drauf. Sondern da steht dann Smart drauf.
Aber das heißt, diese Passwortfrage ist auch gar nicht zu klären?
Also Passwörter sind schwierig, TM. Also das ist ein bekanntes Problem. Wir schlagen uns jetzt schon seit jenseits der 20 Jahre mit der Problematik rum, wie wählt man starke Passwörter, die man sich noch merken kann. Da gibt es nichts von Ratiofarben, da weiß man nicht, gibt es keine einfache Methode, wie das sicher zu machen geht. Man hat diese drei Faktoren, man kann von denen immer nur zwei auswählen.
Aber es ist ja so, gerade bei diesen Smart-Home-Inseln, da muss man das Passwort ja nicht ständig eingeben. Das ist doch eigentlich so eine Sache, die vergibt man einmal und damit ist gut. Also ich verstehe, dass die Motivation, das zu ändern, deswegen noch geringer ist, weil man sich ja eh nicht damit auseinandersetzen muss. Aber im Prinzip wäre es doch da eigentlich am wenigsten ein Problem, sich ein ganz schwieriges Passwort auszudenken und dann halt irgendwo abzuspeichern und aufzuschreiben.
Du hast halt ein Problem. Beim normalen Rechner hast du Tastatur und Monitor dran. Das heißt, du kommst da auch irgendwie noch ran. Wenn du jetzt so ein smartes IoT-Device hast, wo du das Passwort vergessen hast, dann kommst du da unheimlich schwer ran, weil da ist keine Tastatur und kein Bildschirm dran. Das heißt, du musst irgendwie mit einer App, mit irgendwas von außen da drankommen, um auf das Gerät zugreifen zu können. Das heißt, du brauchst eine Möglichkeit, wie du das Gerät mit einem Reset-Knopf zurücksetzen kannst, auf irgendeinen bekannten Wert, der dann auf dem Gehäuse drauf steht. Und dieses Passwort ist halt eigentlich fast immer dann unsicher, weil das wird immer von irgendwas abgeleitet sein. Das wird nie komplett zufällig sein. Und die Faulheit der Leute, nachvollziehbar, das Ding funktioniert ja, ist halt, sie ändern das Standardpasswort nicht, was ab Werk da drin ist.
Naja, aber dieses wird unsicher sein, finde ich Quatsch, weil es gibt Dev Random und da kommt Random raus, Punkt.
Ja, aber wie willst du das in der Produktion machen?
Warte, warte, es gibt was?
Es gibt Dev Random, das ist ein Device, ein Character Device, aus dem man Daten, also wirklich random Daten rauslesen kann, Zufall.
Dev Random ist ein Character Device.
Unter Linux ist das ein Ordner oder eine Datei, die du lesen kannst. Und da kommen, da fallen halt so...
Da steht da eine zufällige Zahl drin.
Die fallen da so raus.
Okay, und dann wird immer noch die Problematik, die müsste man irgendwie dem User mitteilen. Wäre da eine Lösung, dass man sowas sagt wie, okay, wenn du ein Smart Home oder Internet of Things zu Hause hast, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch, dass du ein Smartphone hast? Wir machen das über so ein Nahbereichsding, also Bluetooth oder sowas.
NFC, sowas wäre in der Tat eine coole Geschichte. Du hältst dein Handy da dran und kannst dann auf das Gerät zugreifen im Notfallmodus. Das Problem ist nur auch da, das NFC-Tag muss erstmal beschrieben werden und du musst dann im Herstellungsprozess einen verdammt idiotensicheren Prozess haben, wie du von dem Gerät eindeutig diesen Tag schreiben kannst. Weil wenn dir in der Fabrik irgendwie die Sachen durcheinander kommen, hast du da draußen ein paar Zehntausend Geräte, wo die User nicht mehr darauf zugreifen können, weil dieses NFC-Tag nicht das Passwort gespeichert hat, was im Gerät drin ist. Das heißt, das Gerät müsste dieses NFC-Ding direkt irgendwie betreiben. Dann musst du das ins Gerät einbauen, dann wird es wieder teuer und komplizierter.
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, sozusagen so eine Art Nahbereichsfunkstandard, wo man sagen kann, dass wenn das Gerät angemacht oder resettet wird, würfelt es sich ein Passwort aus.
Das könnte man bauen. Das könnte man sicherlich bauen, das muss aber in das Gerät eingebaut werden. Das kostet dann Geld, das macht die Geräte teuer.
Ja, eine Frage aus dem Publikum?
In der Tat tut das der Google WLAN-Router. Mit dem wird ohne Passwort ausgeliefert und du musst dich per Bluetooth mit dem Ding verbinden und dann ein Passwort setzen. Und vorher macht der erstmal gar nichts.
Also das sozusagen ist eine Möglichkeit, aber das ist sozusagen schon eine fortschrittene Technik, weil da muss halt Bluetooth drin sein und ich muss da sozusagen diese Kommunikation auch dann hinkriegen, oder wie? Aber das will man eigentlich?
Das will man eigentlich. Das ist eine eigentlich ganz gute Möglichkeit. Du könntest auch einen Barcode draufkleben, nur das hat halt das Problem der Zuordnung. Deswegen ist halt sowas, was das Gerät aktiv macht, zum Beispiel über Bluetooth, sicherlich eine ziemlich gute Sache dafür.
Ja, da könnte man nicht auch sozusagen machen, also das ist jetzt so ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik, aber man kann ja auch sagen, das Gerät hat ein kleines Display und darauf wird ein QR-Code abgebildet. Also das hat ja wirklich jedes Handy mittlerweile, einen QR-Code-Leser.
Ja, nur auf dem Router ein Display nur dafür zu haben, ist halt teuer. Also das kostet vielleicht dann 3-4 Euro nochmal extra.
Mit Displays kann man auch ganz viele andere schöne Sachen machen.
Also ja, aber das heißt auch tatsächlich sozusagen, dass die, sag mal jetzt, die Gefahr eines Internet of Things-Botnetzes billigend in Kauf genommen wird. Muss man mal so sagen, oder?
Im Prinzip ja. Du hast halt das Problem einerseits von Herstellern, die sich gerade zwar Gedanken machen, die aber dann eben diesen Supportaufwand haben. Dann hast du eine Klasse von Herstellern, die einfach nur billigst Geräte auf den Markt bringen. Das sind dann irgendwelche, ja, meist chinesischen AliExpress-Lieferanten oder so, wo du für ganz, ganz wenig Geld Geräte bekommst. Und dieser Hersteller existiert in drei Monaten schon gar nicht mehr. Die sich das irgendwo auf dem Restemarkt zusammenkaufen. Dann setzt sich jemand hin, baut das und lötet das irgendwie noch zusammen, dass es funktioniert und schmeißt es auf den Markt.
Kann man jetzt also bei dieser konkreten Attacke, die wir heute zum Anlass nehmen, um diese ganzen Dinge zu nehmen, es fällt ja gerade schon okay, dass bei anderen kleinen Kameras und Babyphones, war das jetzt nur die Geräteklasse oder kann man auch sagen, das war von Marke oder Bauteil sowieso?
Kann man.
Nämlich?
An den Mac-Adressen.
Aber welche? Also...
Von den Endgeräten, die da kommen.
Nein, nein, nein, ich meine, welche Marke war das? Oder war es eine oder waren es zwei oder drei?
Das hab ich jetzt nicht im Kopf, keine Ahnung. Also es gibt da wohl irgendwie Mirai oder so, keine Ahnung.
Mirai ist das Botnetz, ja.
Genau, aber ob das irgendwie in einer Geräteklasse ist, die irgendwie, hab ich jetzt nicht gelesen.
Also es gab auf jeden Fall einen Hersteller, der gesagt hat, wir ziehen jetzt mal alle unsere IP-Kameras zurück.
Und das war ein chinesischer.
Genau, weil die waren wohl hauptsächlich betroffen.
Die sind aber irgendwas mit Yum, Yum, Yum irgendwas.
Und die haben halt im großen Stil jetzt die Kameras zurückgezogen, weil sie feststellten, sie können da gerade keinen Firmware-Update rausrollen, weil sie können irgendwie nicht updaten oder so.
Weil jemand sich in die Geräte eingehakt hat und das Passwort geändert hat?
Nee, weil die wohl, weiß nicht, Auto-Update kaputt haben keine Auto-Update, ich hab das nicht genau verfolgt. Die haben auf jeden Fall die Geräte zurückgezogen, um auch irgendwie den größeren Schaden ihrer Marke abzuwenden oder so.
Ich glaub, die können gar kein Update.
Wahrscheinlich können die kein Update, genau.
Was, das wird ja mal wilder.
Na, Updates sind halt teuer, ne? Also was ich vorhin sagte, du bist Hersteller von so einem Gerät, du kriegst da einmal Geld für, irgendwie deine 40, 50 Euro, dann geht dafür Transport und so weiter alles runter. Es bleibt nicht mehr so viel übrig an dem Geld und dann da noch über Jahre Firmware-Updates raus.
Die Kundennachfrage dafür ist nicht da.
Vor allen Dingen installiert das keiner.
Vor allem erklärt man dem Kunden, dass das Gerät, im Regal gibt es ein Gerät für 40 Euro, das ist dann so ein Fernostding, oder es gibt das für 150. Das für 150 wird auch in zwei Jahren noch Firmware-Updates haben. Das andere nicht. Die Kunden kaufen nicht, das ist teurer.
Die Kunden kaufen ja selbst schon Telefone nicht, also kaufen die billigere Telefone, obwohl klar ist, dass das kein Betriebssystem abgeht.
Obwohl der Vergleich mit dem Preisrecht hinkt.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, ist der Preisentscheid wirklich so groß?
Ja, noch größer. Also wenn ich mir zum Beispiel eine Fritzbox, eine ordentliche, hole, dann kostet die 300 Euro. Und wenn ich etwas Vergleichbares kaufe, kriege ich das für 50, was keine Update kriegt.
Und ihr würdet aber auch sagen, dieser Aufpreis ist nicht der Markenname, sondern auch, man kauft da quasi mit, dass man sozusagen über Jahre Updates kriegt. Und ich finde das auch gerecht.
Ja, natürlich, wenn man wirklich ein kommerzielles Produkt kauft, wo man weiß, dass die wirklich Updates machen, und das macht zum Beispiel AVM, dann kauft man das. Aber da sollte man darauf achten. Das Problem ist, dass der normale Konsument, der guckt halt auf die Packung und sagt, hat dieses Gerät diese technischen Daten, die ich von irgendjemandem gesagt bekommen habe, das ich brauche?
Nee, aber ich glaube, das ist dann auch ein Problem. Das Problem ist sozusagen, der jemand, der dir das sagt, also die zu Weihnachten in die Ferne lande, ich hab das noch nicht, also weder in der Fachpresse, sondern noch sozusagen im Umfeld, ist die Firma updatefähig. Das kenne ich nicht als so ein grundsätzliches Kaufargument, das mitgibt. Das Einzige, wo man das hört, ist immer, wenn es um sozusagen iOS gegen Android geht. Da wird dann immer gesagt, ja, also Apple macht ja wenigstens Updates für seine Geräte und bei Android ist man halt so abhängig davon, ob der Hersteller irgendwas aussieht.
Naja, der Punkt ist, dass du als Benutzer von so einem IoT-Device nicht unbedingt merkst, dass da gerade noch Schadcode draufläuft. Also, es ist so wie mit den sprichwörtlichen Eltern zu Hause, die nicht wissen, auf welche Banner sie nicht klicken dürfen. Deren Computer funktioniert auch noch irgendwie, bis dann die Kinder Weihnachten nach Hause kommen und dann alles wieder schick machen müssen. Aber die Funktionalität, also wenn auch gerade als jemand, der so eine Mailware schreibt, ist das in deren Interesse, dass sie dafür sorgen, dass das Gerät noch weiter funktioniert. Das ist auch bei normalen Viren, die die Menschen normal so anstecken.
Wenn es nicht gerade ein Verschlüsselungs-Ding ist, dann will man so sagen, dass das Gerät weiter läuft.
Obwohl, der funktioniert weiter, nur da die Daten sind halt immer zugrufbar.
Aber erstmal funktioniert auch alles weiter, bis er alles verschlüsselt hat. Aber mit der Preisgeschichte kommt noch eine andere Sache dazu. Der ganze Kram ist so dermaßen komplex, dass du als normaler Konsument das überhaupt nicht mehr durchschaust. Du verstehst die ganzen Begriffe nicht, du verstehst nicht, was du brauchst, was da das Richtige ist. Und dann reduzierst du das Problem auf eine Sache, die du verstehen kannst. Und das ist zum Beispiel der Preis. Und dann kaufst du halt das, was für dich sich besser anfühlt, und das ist halt nur zweifach als günstigere. Da hast du auch das Gefühl, da kannst du nicht so viel falsch machen. Weil wenn das jetzt das Falsche war, hast du nicht so viel Geld dafür ausgeworfen.
Ich will gleich noch mit euch mal drüber genauer sprechen. Dann kommen wir zu dem, was Ben Tom am Anfang der halben Stunde gesagt hat, nämlich wer ist eigentlich schuldig. Und dann gucken, ob man das in Zukunft anders klären könnte. Vorher noch eine letzte Musik vom Chillhop-Album. Und das war ja alles nicht Musik, die man jetzt klischeemäßig mit Computer und Digital zusammenbringt. Der Track ist wenigstens im Namen. Floppy Circus ist es mit Safari Haze. So, letzte halbe Stunde im Chaosradio 228, wo wir über eine DDOS-Attacke aus einem Botnetz, das aus Internet of Things-Geräten zum großen Teil bestanden hat, reden. Und zum Schluss uns der spannenden Frage stellen wollen, wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich schuld daran und wie verhindert man das in Zukunft? Wir haben am Anfang schon ein bisschen drüber geredet, dass das DDOS sozusagen technisch aufhalten vielleicht geht, aber naja, und für die folgende halbe Stunde ist das Gedankenszenario das Folgendes. Also wir haben sozusagen, es gibt so eine große Attacke, die mittels vieler gehackter Geräte aus dem Internet of Things veranschaltet wird. Man will jetzt was dagegen übernehmen, wem hilft man das über? Und wir haben gerade festgestellt, also das wird so sein, dass es Geräte gibt, die regelmäßig keine, also nicht regelmäßig Updates kriegen und deswegen angreifbar sind oder halt einfach auch schlecht gemacht worden sind. Da wollte ich noch was zu sagen, dass es halt nicht ganz alleine der Preis ist. Weil ihr habt ja gerade gesagt, irgendwie teuer gleich viele Updates und so.
Genau, hier kam gerade berechtigt aus dem Publikum der Hinweis, dass der Preis nicht alleine ausschlaggebend sein kann dafür, ob es Updates gibt. Das ist richtig. Es gibt halt Firmen, die sind ein bisschen teurer, die haben Updates. Es gibt Firmen, die sind nicht so teuer, haben auch Updates. Man muss halt wirklich im Einzelfall gucken, ob es zum Beispiel auf der Webseite des Herstellers für diese Geräte so eine Rubrik gibt mit Updates, mit Firmware-Updates, ob da was veröffentlicht wird regelmäßig. Das muss man vor dem Kauf befürchtet tatsächlich tun. Nur zu sagen, dass es jetzt das teurere Gerät ist, keine Garantie dafür, dass es Updates gibt.
Also quasi, wenn das Gerät Geld kostet, das relevant ist, dann steigt die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der Hersteller es sich leisten kann, Updates zu machen. Aber ob er das tut, muss man nochmal nachgucken. Okay, so, jetzt haben wir also diese riesige Botnetzarmee von gehackten Internet of Things-Dingern, die dringend mal irgendwie entweder von Netz abgeklemmt oder......geupdatet....oder geupdatet werden müssen. So, dann gibt es ja verschiedene Parteien, die man in dieser Stelle sozusagen erfolgreich machen kann. Wir wollen mal sozusagen unten anfangen. Der Besitzer. Könnte man in Zukunft einfach sagen, so, lieber Besitzer, wenn du so ein Gerät kaufst, machen wir dich einfach haftbar dafür. Du bist dafür verantwortlich, das Gerät abzuklemmen.
Ja, bitte? Einerseits ist der Besitzer der Einzige, der auf das Gerät Einfluss nehmen kann. Ihm gehört das. Er hat das hoffentlich unter seiner Kontrolle zumindest. Er kann es ausschalten. Er hat physikalische Kontrolle über das Ding. Das Problem ist, der Besitzer selber hat nicht die Möglichkeit, zu überprüfen, ob das Gerät unsicher ist. Er weiß eventuell gar nicht, ob das Gerät an Angriffen mitwirkt. Und ihm da jetzt heftig Schadensersatz überzuhelfen, ist, glaube ich, nicht der richtige Weg. Das sorgt nämlich dafür, dass niemand mehr sich irgendwelche Geräte kauft. Und dann kann man das Internet auch einfach abschalten.
Bin ich dafür?
Nein. Aber gibt es nicht irgendeine Möglichkeit, dass man...
Wenn ich so darüber nachdenke, wahrscheinlich funktionieren würde oder könnte, wäre das, was zum Beispiel die Telekom bei Spamversand macht. Wenn die Telekom Beschwerden bekommt, dass von einem Kunden Spam verschickt wird, wird dieser Kunde, wenn es ein Privatkunde ist, partiell vom Internet abgeklemmt. Er kann keine Mails mehr senden und er bekommt den Hinweis, dass sein Rechner infiziert ist. Das sind Sachen, die durchaus passieren. Und das könnte da auch funktionieren. Das heißt, der ISP würde eine Alarmierung bekommen, dass von seinen Kunden Angriffe ausgehen. Also die Opfer erkennen ja durchaus, dass da eine DDOS-Attacke kommt. Die könnten dann die Angreifer-IP-Adressen, zumindest viele davon, an irgendeiner Clearance-Stelle melden und die informiert dann die Provider, dass von ihren Kunden zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt Angriffe ausgegangen sind.
Wenn sie die IP-Adressen nicht geändert haben.
Wenn sie die IP-Adressen, genau. In einer idealen Welt könnte der Provider dann rausbekommen, welcher Kunde das war und den Kunden mitteilen, pass mal auf, in deinem Netzwerk befinden sich unsere Geräte, wir verwahren dich, wenn das zu oft vorkommt, dann Konsequenz X, zum Beispiel Beendigung des Vertragsverhältnisses. Keine Ahnung. Das Problem ist, man muss bei den Endkunden und muss bei den Benutzern eine Sensibilisierung dafür schaffen, dass auch wenn sie selber gar nicht merken, dass da was im Argen ist, dass anderen Leuten Schaden zufügt und dass sie eigentlich selber Interesse daran haben, dass diese Geräte vom Netz kommen oder abgedatet werden, weil es eben auch sie selber mal betreffen könnte oder eben Dienste, die für sie wichtig sind.
Im Prinzip ist das richtig, aber das Problem dabei ist etwas größer. Und zwar gibt es nicht nur den Standardanschluss mit der Familie dahinter, sondern es gibt Anschlüsse, wo ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz viele Geräte dahinter sind. Und das dann wirklich jemandem aufzubürden und sagen, ja, hier, WG, XY, mach mal.
Oder Krankenhaus oder Arztpraxis oder so.
Entschuldigung, aber das klingt ja auch noch wie eine andere Sache komisch. Also in Deutschland würde ich mir vorstellen, wenn man diese Schritte macht, also Clearingstelle, ISP, Kunde, dann bis diese Nachricht beim Kunden ist, verdauert es ja irgendwie zwei Tage. Das hört sich ja behördlich an. Und dann ist diese DDOS-Attacke auch schon wieder gegessen.
Du willst ja, dass das Gerät geupdatet wird oder dass es vom Netz kommt.
Ja, genau, dass es vom Netz kommt und das geht zu schnell.
Aktuell läuft sowas ja wochenlang und monatelang. Die Geräte sind ja einfach in Betrieb, Wochen und Monate, Tag und Nacht, weil es ist halt so ein IoT-Gerät, das ist Tag und Nacht an. Und auch wenn das dann ein bisschen dauert, bis die Meldung beim Kunden ist, wirst du dann im Kundennetzwerk auch noch nachmessen können und sehen können, von welchen Geräten, von welchen IP-Adressen da immer noch Schleffik ausgeht.
Nicht unbedingt.
Da muss ich jetzt aber noch mal kurz fragen, warum hat denn die Idee des Attacker, über die wir heute reden, aufgehört?
Unklar. Also offensichtlich haben die Macher irgendwann einfach gesagt, wollen nicht mehr, machen wir nicht mehr.
Genau, weil die wahrscheinlich eine TTL hatte.
Und ich möchte den, haben wir am Anfang der Sendung erklärt, heißt sozusagen, dass es irgendwann automatisch aufhört. Aber ich möchte für das Gedankenexperiment schon annehmen, dass die sozusagen, also die pumpt einfach sozusagen weiter, bis wir die vom Netz genommen haben. Und die Frage ist sozusagen, wer ist das? Also was du jetzt beschreibst, ist sozusagen, ja, okay, das geht halt von alleine irgendwann vorbei, dann muss aber trotzdem das Ding noch vom Netz genommen werden. Was ich meine, ist wirklich der Fall. Diese Attacke macht halt sozusagen so lange weiter, bis sie zwangsausgeschaltet wird. Und dann ist ja sozusagen, dann reicht das halt nicht, wenn du dieses ISP-Ding sozusagen machst über, ja, wie ein Familienkunde...
Naja doch. Weil also wie ich ja anfangs schon meinte, das Internet ist halt best effort. Wie gesagt, das ist auch so ein bisschen der Bildungsauftrag des CCC.
Das ist kaputt.
Da können wir nicht unbedingt schnell was dran ändern. Wir können jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen, so Alarm, Feueralarm, alle auf Knöpfe drücken und dann ist das Thema gegessen. Sondern wir können halt sagen, okay, wir haben jetzt diese Attacke, da können wir jetzt erst mal zwei Tage lang nichts dran machen. Okay, müssen wir mitleben. Sondern wir gehen jetzt hin und gehen halt diesen Weg über den ISP, oder das Opfer, das sagt, okay, ich habe hier von folgenden IPs irgendwie Attacken bekommen, leite das doch mal bitte schon weiter an deine Heimat-ISP und dann ist der dafür verantwortlich, dann rauszufinden, wer das denn vielleicht war. Aber jetzt irgendwie hin zu sagen, okay, wir müssen jetzt hier Cyber-Cyber-Bundeswehr im Inneren, ist nicht zielführend.
Naja, aber das ist genau das, was ich gerade gemerkt habe. Die Gefahr gibt es natürlich doch, weil in dem Moment, wo ich sozusagen die ISPs dafür verantwortlich mache, passieren, kann ich mir zwei Dinge vorstellen. Das erste ist, ISPs fangen an, ihren Traffic zu monitorn, damit sie sozusagen schneller reagieren können. Und dann hat man was, was vorhin schon mal bei DNS noch sozusagen ein Gegenargument war, dass man sagt, okay, der ISP guckt jetzt in den Datenverkehr, um rauszufinden, wie nein.
Nein, das muss man ganz klar trennen. Einmal gibt es sogenannte Abuse-Nachrichten, dass man einmal sagt, okay, von folgender IP wurde ich geschädigt. Das hatte ich nicht zu interessieren, wie, sondern ich wurde von folgender IP geschädigt. Natürlich muss man da irgendwie Missbrauch vorbeugen, aber dazu muss der ISP nicht in meine Daten gucken. Das ist ja ähnlich wie mit Spam. Da wird gesagt, okay, von dieser IP wurde Spam gesendet. Das wird nicht kontrolliert, sondern wird erstmal irgendwie verwarnt. Also gerade bei den dynamischen IPs ist das weniger ein Problem, weil man kann ja gucken, bei den Kunden ändern sich ja die IPs über die 24 Stunden jeweils. Und wenn diese Attacke über diese 24 Stunden hinweg persistent bleibt für einen bestimmten Kunden über verschiedene IPs, kann man daraus zurückschließen, dass da was im Argen sein muss bei den Kunden.
Und das andere ist, wenn ein ISP das machen muss, dann steht ja viel mehr Aufwand. Es gab für diese Attacke, die wir hatten, gab es so Heatmaps, also wo kommen die Angriffe eigentlich her? Das war tatsächlich auch sozusagen, konnte man das lokal festmachen, wo ganz viele dieser Geräte gehackt wurden. Und da hat ein ISP ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz viel aufgerissen. Und dann sagt er, na gut, dann werden meine Kosten aber höher. Das wird dann irgendwie umgeschlagen.
Es gibt eine Buttikumsfrage.
Na, gleich, aber da möchte ich gerne, dass ihr erst mal auf diesen Punkt sozusagen eingeht. Das würde ja Internet teurer machen. Also, dann wird sich ISP wahrscheinlich irgendwas ausdenken von wegen...
Du hast aber die Forderung gestellt, dass wir jetzt unbedingt was machen müssen.
Er hat vor allem...
Nee, nee, nee, ich habe gesagt, ich möchte jetzt verschiedene Verantwortliche durchgehen und das für und wieder besprechen wollen.
Letztlich ist halt alles kacke.
Internet of Shit ist... Das würde ich gerne genauer erläutern.
Wenn du jetzt anfängst und sagst, der Provider ist verantwortlich, dann sagt das...
Was hast du gesagt? Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Der Provider sollte seine Kunden informieren und die sollen das dann abklemmen. Was hast du gesagt? Das hast du auf mich nicht angeschlagen. Dazu brauchen wir bei den Kunden eine Änderung, eine Einstellung, dass sie sagen, mir ist das nicht scheißegal, mein Rechner läuft doch, sondern dass sie merken, dass man da zusammenarbeiten muss. Das ist ein soziales Problem, das man mit Technik mal wieder nicht lösen kann. Deswegen glaube ich auch nicht, dass das so schnell passieren wird, wenn überhaupt. Solange haben wir technische Krücken. Nur wenn wir jetzt hinkommen und sagen, der Provider ist verantwortlich, wird es eben genau zudem führen. Der Provider wird dann irgendwelche Filter und Monitoringlösungen installieren. Der wird sich angucken, ob er von seinen Kunden bekannte Alltage sieht und wird dann die Kunden abklemmen. Das ist eigentlich nicht eine Welt, in der wir leben wollen.
Also, weil dann gab es ja auch Kollateralschein, aber das habt ihr auch schon gesagt. Dann klemst du halt, sagen, an den ganzen Internetzugang ab.
Und dann ist halt plötzlich irgendeine Klinik offline oder irgendwas anderes. Das ist halt auch doof.
Nee, eigentlich mehr eine Aussage. Und zwar, inzwischen gibt es ja sogar Netzwerke, die proaktiv nach Sicherheitslücken zum Beispiel von Windows-Geräten oder sonstigen Scannen und daraus Abuse-Mails generieren.
Meine Frage ist, würde das dabei auch helfen?
Nee, weil vor allen Dingen ist halt die Angriffsfläche so unglaublich groß. Also ich meine, ok, du könntest vielleicht nach den Standard-Fehren suchen, wie irgendwie Standard-Passwörter vergeben. Aber das ist ja nur die am einfachsten verständliche Sicherheitslücke, da gibt es ja noch unglaublich viele andere, die da eventuell zum Tragen kommen. Wenn du sie nicht kennst, kannst du nicht danach suchen.
Aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, sind ja diese ganzen riesigen Attacken nicht dadurch geschehen, dass irgendjemand einen total krass ausgefuchsten Fehler hat, sondern, wie habt ihr selber gesagt, dass mittlerweile spekuliert wird, das sind sozusagen Leute, die einfach irgendwie Baukastensysteme benutzt haben und Standard-Passwörter.
Es sind halt Standard-Sachen, auch diese Amplifier, das sind Protokolle wie NTP, die eigentlich zur Zeitsynchronisation da sind, oder auch DNS selber kann man für so eine Amplification-Attacke benutzen. Da sind zum Teil Schwachstellen in Protokollen, da sind zum Teil Server, die nicht gut gewartet sind. Da kommt sehr viel zusammen und deswegen werden wir die Ursachen oder die ausnutzbaren Systeme auf lange, lange Zeit nicht loswerden.
Aber dann könnte doch genau sowas helfen, was gerade vorgeschlagen wurde oder nicht. Also quasi, wenn wir schon mal die ganzen offensichtlichen Fehler dadurch sozusagen minimieren können, dass man aktiv danach sucht.
Du hast ein Problem. Das ist das, dass du sehr wenige, also im Vergleich sehr wenige Systeme brauchst, um eine Attacke fahren zu können. Das heißt, auch wenn du jetzt 80 Prozent der Systeme, die jetzt verwundbar sind, loswirst, es kommen ständig neue dazu. Und wenige Server oder wenige Systeme können ausreichen, um auch wieder Attacken zu fahren. Deswegen auch wenn du, also es ist ein relativ aussichtsloser Kampf gegen Windmühlen, die alle loszuwerden, die da so verwundbar sind. Das ist leider so.
Der beste Ansatz ist halt einfach, die Geräte sicherer zu machen.
Da wollte ich jetzt gerade darauf zu reden kommen, lasst uns doch einfach die Hersteller der Verfahren, was ich machen soll, liebe Hersteller, ihr dürft einfach keine Geräte mehr verkaufen, wo ihr nicht die Möglichkeit habt, per Auto-Update sozusagen genau so was abzuschalten oder halt aufzuspielen. So fertig ist die Kiste. Die Dinger sind am Netz, das ist das Argument, dem ihr das verkauft. Ihr müsst jetzt einfach dafür sorgen, dass da sicherer Code drauf ist. Und wenn ihr das nicht könnt, dann müsst ihr dafür sorgen, dass ihr jederzeit nachschieben könnt, wenn da die Erzeugungen sind.
Und dann machst du die nächste Box der Pandora auf. Dann hast du nämlich Geräte, die sich vom Hersteller aus der Ferne updaten lassen.
Was könnte da schon schief gehen?
Dann hast du halt einen Staat, der sagt, wir haben jetzt hier so einen Terroristen und wir möchten jetzt alles über diesen Terroristen wissen oder wir bezeichnen ihn als Terroristen. Und dann wird der Hersteller verpflichtet, dem eine ganz spezielle Firmware auf seine Geräte zugepacken. Das ist halt auch blöd. Auf der anderen Seite, ohne Auto-Updates ist es auch doof, weil die Leute die Updates nicht manuell einspielen werden. Beispiel von diesen Aldi-Kameras. Das heißt, auch da kommst du sehr, sehr schnell wieder in Bedrohliche. Was du da eigentlich möchtest, ist, dass die Leute im Prinzip eine informierte Entscheidung treffen können, dass sie diese Updates jetzt haben wollen. Das ist per Default gerne auch an, aber sie können es auch jederzeit abschalten, wenn sie der Meinung sind, dass zum Beispiel die Updates dafür sorgen, dass eine kritische Infrastruktur nicht mehr funktioniert. Was auch immer in dem Zusammenhang jetzt eine kritische Infrastruktur ist.
Diese Auto Updates haben aber noch andere Sachen, und zwar der Hersteller kann theoretisch dafür sorgen, dass nach dem fünften Update die Geräte sich ausschalten und nicht mehr funktionieren.
Nicht nur der Hersteller.
Ja genau, wenn diese Update-Funktion dann kaputt ist, kannst du selbst die Geräte dann auch kaputt machen. Also das ist irgendwie blöd. Das Beste, es gibt eine Möglichkeit. Und zwar gibt es ja Open Source Software. Es gibt so OpenWRT und so weiter. Und man kann, wenn der Hersteller sagt, ok, ich gebe meine ganzen Source Code an die freie Community, dann ist das, wenn er die Treiber zum Beispiel in den Körner packt, dann ist das fast schon garantiert, dass die Körner Community das weiter pflegt. Das heißt, er braucht sich da eigentlich nicht darum zu kümmern. Es muss dann nur von dem Besitzer darauf geachtet werden, dass die Updates eingespielt werden.
Aber da sind wir bei dem Punkt, wir haben ja gerade festgestellt, der Besitzer ist raus, weil er wird es wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Aber dann bleibt nur Auto-Updates und Auto-Updates ist blöd.
Und diese Fire Software funktioniert leider auch nicht immer. Ich habe zu Hause einen Router, der war sehr verbreitet, da gibt es keine Updates mehr für. Auch nicht bei OpenWRT.
Kann man nicht einfach sagen, okay, ihr Hersteller, ihr seid nicht zur Auto-Updates verloren, aber wir machen euch für größere Schäden haffbar, wenn euch Fahrlässigkeit nachgewiesen werden kann. Also Beispiel, wenn ihr tatsächlich sozusagen so ein Ding ausliefert, das irgendwie offen ist wie ein Show & Tour und Admin als User und Passwort 1, 2, 3, 4 als Passwort hat, dann und daraus wird ein Botnetz gebastelt, dann seid ihr leider dran.
Ja, okay, aber jetzt hab ich meinen nicht in der Kühlschrank. Den hab ich mir jetzt gekauft. So, und dann, wie machst du jetzt den Hersteller, der vor zwei Jahren schon irgendwie Konkurs angemeldet hat und nicht mehr existiert, haffbar? Oder machst du einen Importeur, haffbar? Oder wie machst du, haffbar?
Es gibt, ich hab neulich gelernt sozusagen, dass es in Deutschland ein Elektro-Gesetz, Elektro-Geräte-Gesetz gibt und da ist das wie folgt geregelt, also Geräte brauchen Prüfzeichen und der Hersteller ist haffbar. Und wenn du als Händler Geräte verkaufst, die keinen sozusagen Kennzeichen haben, dann bist du, dann giltst du als Händler, als Hersteller. Also du hast dann auf jeden Fall sozusagen jemand, den du haffbar machen kannst. Also die Frage ließe sich zumindest juristisch auch klären.
Ja und dann bestelle ich bei Aliexpress in China direkt. Das Ganze wird über einen Freihaufen in England nach Deutschland geliefert. Es kommt hier eine LED-Lampe an, in meinem konkreten Beispiel. Die LED-Lampe ist außen blank mit 230 Volt, hat keine Prüfzeichen, darf eigentlich gar nicht in den Verkehr kommen, ist höchst illegal, kommt aber durch alles durch.
Naja, ist da aber auch sozusagen ein bedeutlicher Einzelfall. Das ist ja halt nicht so, dass wir dann sozusagen hunderte Geräte im freien Markt haben werden.
Ja, aber wenn wir das weiter spinnen, den Gedanken, dann haben wir irgendwann wieder die Grenzen zu. Das will auch keiner.
Aber generell, wenn man sozusagen Hersteller zu zwingen könnte, also es ist anscheinend nicht umsetzbar, aber die Idee, Hersteller haftbar zu machen, halte ich nicht für grundsätzlich falsch.
Nicht grundsätzlich, aber...
Es kommt auf die konkrete Ausgestaltung an. Also der Worst Case ist halt, du machst einen Hersteller von WLAN-Routern dafür verantwortlich, was da drauf an den Firmware läuft. Und die vernageln das Ding dann so, dass du auch keine freie Firmware mehr drauf machen kannst, auch nicht mehr als Experte, der sich da mit beschäftigt. Und dann haben wir halt irgendwie das Ende von freier Software auf WLAN-Routern. Weil der Hersteller sagt sich, ich bin dafür haftbar und im Zweifelsfall muss ich nachweisen, dass auf diesem einen Router da irgendwie meine Firmware drauf war und die sicher ist und nicht irgendwas anderes. Und wenn dann der Kunde kurzfristig meine Firmware wieder draufmacht, dann kann ich nicht nachweisen und hin und her. Das ist, glaube ich, eine Sache, die wir auch nicht haben wollen. Was wir halt bräuchten statt Industrie 4.0 und so weiter bräuchten, wäre sowas wie Brain 1.0. Also wir müssen halt echt den Leuten klar machen, was sie da haben, ein paar Grundkenntnisse vermitteln und sie in irgendeiner Art und Weise befähigen zu erkennen, wenn dieser Kram Mist baut.
Und deswegen machen wir dieses Chaosradio, es gibt noch eine Publikumsmeldung.
Wir gehen gerade den umgekehrten Weg mit dem Firmware-Lockdown. Wir werden eine Situation haben, dass immer mehr Geräte gar keine Firmware mehr haben, die man frei updaten kann. Und die Hersteller werden da nicht hinterher kommen. Verstehe ich nicht. Darf der Hersteller darauf verzichten, Updates für ein Gerät anzubieten? Wann ist die Obsoleszenz gegeben? Also wie alt darf das Gerät sein? Also wir müssen es alle drei Jahre wegschmeißen. Oder alle zwei. Oder soll der Hersteller verpflichtet sein, für zehn Jahre alte Geräte Updates anzubieten? Weil die Dinger gehen ja nicht kaputt.
Früher hatten wir sowas ja mal. Wir hatten ja früher durchaus den Fall, dass Hersteller damit geworben haben, wenn sie diese Schalter in ihr Haus einbauen, garantieren wir für die nächsten 20 Jahre, dass sie Ersatzteile bekommen.
Also ich finde das nicht undenkbar.
Nein, das gibt es ja auch in der Industrie. In der Industrie ist das Standard. Hier gibt es Laptops, wo der Hersteller sagt, 10 Jahre kriegst du die.
Ich muss dir das Auto als Vergleich bemühen, weil das hält ja auch ein paar Jahre. Oder Waschmaschinen oder sowas.
Auto geht ja noch viel länger. Die meisten Autos kriegen so 20, 25 Jahre Abteile.
Aber dass es garantiert wird sozusagen. Also es wird garantiert, so lange Waschmaschine garantiert.
Die muss aber nur weltweit sein, nicht unbedingt. Das muss aber dann weltweit funktionieren. Wenn ich jetzt nach Thailand in Urlaub fliege und sie da die Dollar Food device, total geil, kauf ich jetzt, nehm ich mit. Weil gibt's hier nicht.
Also ich seh schon, im Grunde genommen ist das alles schlimm.
Sehr schlimm.
Gut, wie gehen wir da jetzt weiter vor? Weil was ja nicht die Lösung sein soll, wir werfen mal alles weg. Also Bento war ja dafür, das Internet abzuschalten, alle Geräte zu verbrennen.
Ich seh einfach nicht ein, warum man einen Toaster-Wilhelm braucht.
Na gut, aber würdest du jemanden, der...
Damit der Wetterbericht drauf getoastet wird.
Genau. Du willst es nicht, aber würdest du sagen, jemandem die Begeisterung absprechen wollen, dass er sich dafür interessiert und einen coolen Hack findet, dass er einen Toaster-Wilhelm hat?
Das wäre Zensur. Ich will eigentlich eher nur davor warnen, dass man sich halt diesem ganzen Konsumerdrang irgendwie hingibt und jetzt nur, weil es eine App für deinen Toaster gibt, den ich jetzt diesen Toaster zu kaufen, der jetzt mit deinem Handy sprechen kann und einfach nur die ganz genaue braunen Note in deinen Toaster toastet, halte ich natürlich für drüber nachdenkenswert. Also ich würde den Leuten sehr stark raten, darüber nachdenken. Das ist schon okay.
Aber ganz ehrlich, es gibt viele Internet of Things-Ansätze, die finde ich total interessant und die mache ich nur nicht aus genau dieser Überlegung. Aber ich würde eigentlich gerne.
Das Problem ist, ich glaube, wir müssen einen ganz großen schönen Spagat hinkriegen. Und zwar müssen wir den Herstellern sagen, hey, pass mal auf, du kannst das mit den Updates, mit ein bisschen Sponsoring und so weiter und Open-Source-Software eigentlich ganz einfach haben.
Bau doch einfach geiler Hardware.
Genau. Und gib von der Hardware ein bisschen Sponsoring weg an die Open-Source-Community. Und dann machen die das für dich. Wenn du den kompletten Source freigibst, dann machen die das. Da sehen wir wunderbar, was zum Beispiel gerade gezeigt wurde, das Raspberry Pi oder Android-Handys. Mein Handy zum Beispiel kriegt offiziell von Google, es ist ein Google Nexus 5, kriegt offiziell kein neues Nougat. Ich habe aber ein Nougat drauf, weil die Community gesagt hat, ich habe davon eins, ich mache das. Und dann geht das.
Und der andere Punkt ist dann wahrscheinlich die User.
Ja, die sollte man so ein bisschen anstupsen, dass sie halt sagen, okay, ich kümmere mich drum, das ist halt auch ein Device, was ich beobachten muss, wo ich im Kopf haben muss, ich mache dafür Updates, ich muss da auch mal klicken.
Oder halt der totale Overkill-Ansatz, ich habe halt nicht mehr ein Netzwerk zu Hause, sondern das Netzwerk ist in mehrere Subnetze unterteilt und ich habe dann da so mein Entertainment-Netzwerk, da ist so der Fernseher drin und der ganz andere Scheiß, das darf aber nicht mehr so richtig, das ist ja nett.
Das ist ein Nerd-Ansatz.
Das macht die IETF. HomeNet, so was kommt.
Aber das hilft ja sozusagen nicht daran. Also warte mal, das grundlegende Ding ist doch, ich möchte...
So ein Local-Doment.
Bitte, wir müssen wirklich gleich los machen. Wenn ihr jetzt mit solchen Worten um euch wirft, dann würde das nicht funktionieren. Was ich fragen will ist, wenn so ein Gerät ins Internet will, dann muss es ja ins Internet, es ist ja egal, ob es in einem sozusagen Local, was auch immer ist.
Aber muss es alles dürfen?
Genau, aber wenn es irgendwas darf, ist das doch sozusagen fehleranfällig oder nicht?
Ja.
Also um die Nummer mit den Updates kommen wir noch nicht rum, oder?
Nö.
Gut, dann mache ich an dieser Stelle Schluss. Ich bedanke mich bei Sokrates, Bento und Montags. Und verabschiede mich mit dem gewohnten Song und den Worten. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe eine Nachricht an euch. Verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups und macht Gottverdammt nochmal eure Updates.